I watched thousands of hours of TED
Talks my team and I actually coded every
single Ted Talk that was posted from
2010 looking for patterns I wanted to
know what were the differences between
the most viewed and the least viewed TED
Talks you know if you watch Ted these
are all successful smart people why is
it that some videos get millions of
views and some get thousands of views we
cataloged every single queue we could
find we clocked a number of smiling we
looked at stage presence we looked at
gestures one of the big things that we
found was that the really good speakers
they use space to their advantage and
they would use leans when they really
wanted you to pay attention so in my
videos often when I'm sharing something
that I think is really important or I
really want to emphasize it I'll
literally lean into the camera like this
is it and I think it wakes people up
like it immediately makes people like oh
she's leaning in when I lean in a video
I get more replays on that section and I
get more engagement so a lean is a small
one but it's so powerful